the Queen came out in support of Prince  Harry and Megan Merkel's decision to  step away from being full-time members  of the royal family she actually gave  her approval but now the Queen has to  find a new successor to the throne and  that's gonna be hard to do she's really  gonna have to scrape the bottom of the  barrel of the extended royal family the  pickings are not good for example Sir  Albert the Earl of cross sandwich is  yeah yeah there's the R is Rebecca the  Duchess of inbreeding there's Kevin King  of Queens that's not a yeah countess  Margaret for pinkies yeah and finally  fraternal twins Sir mix-a-lot and Sir  Mix a little  yeah yeah we assigned our best people to  that one  [Laughter]